Let's bring out Billy Bush.
He is the former co-host
of The Today Show,
he was also on that other sh--
Ah, you know what happened,
Billy Bush is over here.
There you go.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
Give him a nice
round of applause.
He deserves one after all
this time. How are you?
Hello, sir, thank you
very much.
-So, I had Kathy Griffin on
last week...
-Oh, good.
-...and I feel like
this is my month
to rehabilitate people...
(LAUGHTER)
...who should not have been
made to go away.
-Ah.
-This country--
-I'd like to get back
to normal.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
Exactly. Yeah.
Uh, as we know, you were a...
you know, the guy
in the bus with the President
when he said those nasty things
about grabbing pussy.
-Um...
-(SPARSE LAUGHTER)
First, let's just ask how
you would have handled it
differently now that you look,
can look, back.
Uh, probably would have just
changed the topic. I mean,
I spent a lot of time
with Trump back then, because--
Yeah, I didn't realize that,
that you...
and Trump, you were--
Eight pageants--
Well, I was the ex--
-I was the entertainment
correspondent for NBC...
-Right.
-...and he--
-And he was the cash cow.
He was the cash cow,
he was pulling 20 million
viewers a week or something,
so I'm with him two, three
times a week...
You had to kiss his ass.
Yeah... I... sort of.
You sort of meet them
where they are.
Or you can interrupt him
and then...
You know how volatile he is,
right? So, he'd be like,
"I hate Billy Bush, he's done.
Moving on.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Entertainment Tonight only.
Forget Billy Bush, he's--"
And then...
-I have to explain why I lost...
-Right.
-...the Trump, the big fish.
-Right. So-- Okay.
So, and I'm sure everybody
says this to you, but,
it is weird that he kept
his job and you lost yours.
Uh...
-Little irony.
-Yeah.
And... how has that
made you feel
the last year and a half?
-Are you over--
-(SIGHS) Shitty.
-Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Are you over-- Is it--
I'm sure there was a period
of bitterness?
Yeah. Oh, yeah, it's definitely,
uh...
It's-- In the beginning,
you know, it's, um...
-BILL: Let it out.
-It's chaos, right? It's...
You got order in your life,
and then, all of a sudden,
in an instant, you have chaos.
-BILL: Right.
-And you don't know end is up
and there's paparazzi
all over the place and you're--
You're wondering
if you're gonna be okay,
"Am I done? Am I-- I don't know"
and then you go into the--
the whole thing, but...
Then you sort of come out.
Oddly enough...
the day that Trump walked
into the Oval Office
was the day
that I walked into a, uh...
self-help retreat in Northern
California to sort of get back
on my feet,
it's called The Hoffman Process,
I go up there, and, uh...
I'm seven days off the grid,
I'm like the guy from Ohio there
who knew too little.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Uh, you know, no phones,
no nothing.
-Wow.
-And, um... and that was
the beginning of just...
getting over it. Look, I mean,
things happen to people.
All in all, my life...
-is pretty good. I got--
-BILL: Right.
-I got great kids, I got a--
a great family--
-BILL: Yeah.
And life is random. Bad...
Bad things happen
to good people.
Good things happen
to bad people.
That's why people
like me are atheists.
How about you?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHTER)
Did it make you
lose your faith?
Bill, I thought you'd like this.
I'm donating the $850 I get
to appear here
to the Church in Los Angeles,
just 'cause I-- I thought you--
(LAUGHTER)
-I am. I, uh...
-(SPARSE APPLAUSE)
-Okay. I won't try
to convert you.
-But, no, you-- Look.
External events
you can't control, right?
-Right. Exactly.
-I did a whole bunch of
self-help work.
You can't control what happens.
You can only control how you
react to it, how you handle it.
And it took me a while,
but then I said,
"Wait a minute, hold on.
Things are pretty good,
get back on your feet," and, uh,
I took my daughter to Japan.
She's 13 years old, obsessed
with Japanese culture.
We went there for ten days.
I got a trip planned with my,
uh, with my middle daughter.
I'm doing a little time--
You know, things
like that that--
It's just... You ever--
You ever wonder what happens
to you if, like,
everything went away?
The big career, the big show,
HBO, the whole thing.
What-- What does happen?
Oh, it's flashed before my eyes
many times.
(LAUGHTER)
-It's, uh--
-Right when I said it.
Right when I said it.
Only on a-- (LAUGHS)
On a weekly basis.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-But, can I-- Yeah, exactly.
-Twice already in the show
so far.
-But, can I ask you a few
things about Donald? 'Cause--
-Yeah.
You obviously do know him
better than-- than most.
-Well, I did.
-First of all, um... Did he
have a type? Like, you know,
like, in-- in the Fire and Fury
book, Michael Wolff says,
you know,
like, his whole life was based
around chasing women.
Like, Bill Clinton,
-he didn't have a type.
-Well, I wasn't that close
with him.
I-- I mean, I saw him on camera
here and there but I did host,
you know, four Miss USA pageants
and four Universe pageants
for NBC at the time, and, uh...
You know, he's yeah, he's
definitely a-- You know,
he would come backstage,
-all the reports you've heard
of, you know...
-Right.
...coming backstage
and reviewing the guard like,
you know,
Kim Jong-Un reviews
the military.
He comes back
with the tie that's too long,
past the belt, and the overcoat
and... Uh...
Yeah, but I think,
um...
We all-- We know
about Donald Trump, right?
We know who the guy is.
Well, the story that I love
that I think is so indicative
is when you called him
on the ratings once.
You said--
Because The Apprentice was like
number 30 and he was saying
it's number one.
Well, he's been saying
number one forever, right?
-And, his...
-And finally, I'd had enough.
I said, "Wait. Donald. Hold it.
Wait a minute.
You haven't been number one
for like five years, four years,
whatever it is.
Not in any category,
not in any demo."
He goes, "Well, did you see
last Thursday?
Last Thursday, 18 to 49,"
uh, whatever, last five minutes
or whatever,
I, you know... "No, I don't know
that stat, no, I--"
So, he's like, "I told you."
And then later, after
when the cameras are off,
he says, uh, he goes,
"Billy, look. Look.
You just tell them,
and they believe it. That's it.
You just tell them
and they believe it."
-(AUDIENCE GROANS)
-"They just do."
-And I said, "Ah... Okay."
-And that's where we are.
-And that--
-So, from that point forward,
Access Hollywood was always
number one. We-- We were
number two.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-But the fact that he can
do that to America now,
I mean, because that's exactly
what he does all the time.
He just says it,
-and they believe it, right?
People do.
-Yeah.
Um, he never said he was sorry
to you, right? I mean, he never
has said he's sorry--
-Did the phone ring?
-His lies. Yeah.
Well, he didn't do it. I mean,
in fairness, he didn't,
-you know, leak the tape,
but, uh...
-And did--
-I didn't want him to call.
I don't wanna talk about this.
-Right.
I haven't spoken to him
in three, four years.
I have to ask one more thing.
Did you actually give him
the Tic Tac...
-when he asked for the Tic Tac?
-(LAUGHTER)
-Because I always thought that--
-"Sir, your Tic Tacs
are right here."
I always thought the Tic Tac
was sort of, like, the--
like a Columbo episode.
That was the little detail
that-- that showed that
he wasn't--
This wasn't just locker-room
but he was really gonna do it,
-because why else do you need
the Tic Tac?
-No--
If you're not
gonna kiss somebody,
why "Billy, give me a Tac"?
-(LAUGHTER)
-"Tac me."
Thirteen years ago, I kissed
a lot of ass, but that's where
I drew the line.
-No Tic Tac, I don't provide.
-So, you did not give him
the Tic Tac?
I did not give him--
I draw the line.
I am so glad to have found that
out, ladies and gentlemen.
-No Tic Tac.
-(APPLAUSE)
(PETE LAUGHS)